les doy la bienvenida al espacio de
cultura de france24 obras de arte
rociadas con sopa o puré estatuas
cubiertas de crema el museo es el nuevo
objetivo de ciertos activistas
medioambientales dispuestos a chocar
para movilizar desde hace unas semanas
circulan imágenes de varias de estas
acciones provocando fuertes reacciones
tanto en el público como en los
gobiernos el momento no es casual porque
la conferencia de las Naciones Unidas
sobre el cambio climático más conocida
como cop27 empezó el 6 de noviembre en
Egipto al atacar a los museos esos
militantes ecologistas dicen querer
cuestionar nuestras prioridades y
nuestro sistema de valores lo que es
sagrado o no en esta época de crisis
climática vienen entre otros países de
Reino Unido Italia o España echamos un
vistazo a quienes son estos y cuáles son
sus motivaciones
ha habido mensajes de odio Por supuesto
y ha habido mensajes de apoyo porque la
gente se da cuenta de que esto es un
acto proporcional a un gobierno criminal
la inacción del gobierno es criminal no
soy una criminal no soy una niña
asustada que intenta luchar por su
futuro
y martes hoy están enfadados porque
hemos ensuciado un vidrio de protección
que mañana estará limpio pero sus hijos
no tendrán comida dentro de unos años
deberíamos explotar de rabia porque nos
arriesgamos a un futuro de muerte Guerra
y hambre los gobiernos lo saben si
queremos proteger el arte tenemos que
proteger nuestras vidas y nuestro futuro
como ciudadanas y actuar con
desobediencia civil y aunque sea un
proceso bastante horrible A menos en lo
personal es algo que lo veo necesario
porque estamos luchando por nuestra vida
y necesitamos actuar Ya lo hemos hecho
en otros sitios y por eso y no nos han
hecho ni caso y por eso lo hemos hecho
en el museo en ningún momento hemos
dañado el arte solo queríamos lanzar ese
mensaje
[Aplausos]
cambiamos de tema para hablar de la
adaptación a la pantalla chica del
exitoso ensayo autobiográfico de Tamara
terendaum El Fin Del Amor esta comida
dramática se estrenó en Amazon Prime
video y cuenta cómo nacida y criada en
una comunidad judía ortodoxana el
corazón de Buenos Aires la filosofa
Argentina empezó a deconstruir
prohibiciones y tahues sociales en torno
al amor y al sexo en un viaje de
autoconocimiento la cantante y actriz
Lali espósito lidera el elenco de esta
serie y reverante sobre los vínculos la
religión y la libertad veamos el trailer
Sé que soy infumable y les pediría
disculpas pero siento que es otro acto
narcisista Así que agradecer tenés un
resentimiento muy grande
puede ser vas a bailar en mi pasado
Serás un secreto por siempre guardado
termina esta noche y después que me
gusta no estoy aquí
porque todo tiene que ser una tragedia
para ustedes bailarás en mí
pasamos ahora a nuestra sección dedicada
a la música con Los homenajes a la
cantante brasileña gal Costa era una de
las mayores Voces del país y una figura
destacada la tropicalismo un movimiento
de Gran carga política que surgió en
desafío a la dictadura militar de la
época y que fusionó el folclor local y
las tradiciones afrobasileñas con las
influencias del rock psicodélico del
extranjero calco está falleció a los 77
años escuchamos algunas reacciones del
mundo artístico brasileño nunca
pensé que llegaría el día en que tendría
que hablar del dolor de la pérdida de
calcio
siempre cautivó con su voz única y
magistral hoy está llorando
todos para allí rompió todos los
paradigmas todas las fronteras rompió
las barreras para mi Generación fue la
más Revolucionaria de las cantantes
en otras noticias musicales el rápido
francés Dino se estrenó un ambicioso
cuarto albuma y ver apague o inviernos
en París con este disco más melancólico
que nunca y que ya es un éxito en las
plataformas de streaming Dinos vuelve a
demostrar que es uno de los mejores
raperos del momento en Francia
[Música]
y destacamos también al nuevo tema del
Jamaica no estadounidense más seguro say
you want me cantautor pero también
saxofonista con esta canción una idea de
lo que podemos esperar de su próximo
álbum
[Música]
Nos despedimos con la colaboración los
rockera entre abril Lavinia y John broad
el sencillo se llama I'm mes Gracias a
ustedes por su confianza y sigan con
nosotros hay más cultura en Frost 24 y
Frozen
[Música]
[Aplausos]